i have no qualms in saying that the
testaments by margaret atwood was one of
the more profound reading experiences
that i have had in a long time
it follows on from the handmaid's tale
published all the way back in 1985
but you don't need to have read that to
appreciate this book
if you didn't know it is a dystopian
novel based in gilead
a theocratic patriarchal america where
women are brutally repressed
and the law is a twisted version of the
old testament
you could say that this is a book about
escaping that dystopia or bringing it
down
but that's not what it's really about
the testaments
is an interrogation of faith and
institutional religion
how it affects how we view ourselves and
others and the world around us
even in ways that we might not realize
and how hard it is to deconstruct
beliefs that we have
incorporated into who we are both
harmful ones
and harmless ones and what that can feel
like for someone
that emotional experience is just
utterly engrossing
and when i read this one line it was
just so
raw and real for me and i want to read
it to you too
i feared i might lose my faith if you've
never had a faith
you will not understand what that means
you feel as if your best friend is dying
that everything that defined you as
being burned away
you'll be left all alone you feel exiled
as if you were lost in a dark wood it
was like the feeling i'd had when
tabitha died
the world was emptying itself of meaning
everything
was hollow everything was withering
i really felt that
i don't talk a lot about my personal
life you know on the channel
or on here but um you know i was raised
in a christian home
and i went to church for 25 years of my
life and i am
25 by the way as in i only just
stopped going really when
i've been asked you know oh why did you
stop why'd you cut it off
now i don't really have
a clear answer you know for either them
all for myself
and that's the uncomfortable
disconcerting thing
you know it's it's easy for me to say oh
my friends have mostly left my friends
have moved on
you know i don't have a huge number of
social ties to that community
anymore but at the same time
i've been on a long journey
of questioning why i believe
what i believe and
faith is complicated because it's part
of who i
am and who i've always been but suddenly
it's a
whole lot more nebulous
and a lot less concrete the testaments
was a really personal read for me
because there's this character who is
realizing they don't really believe
these things anymore
trying to rationalize them reshape them
refit them put them back in the box and
realizing they can't
maybe letting go trying to figure out
who i am without that it was
really confronting because when people
ask hey what do you believe now
i don't really have an answer like i'm
knowing myself less and less
and some things you're gonna turn on
dramatically and suddenly
you know i don't believe that anymore
and
other things you just sort of
drift with on the surface of it all
but not really immersed in it anymore
and those things are almost harder to
let go of there's this temptation when
writing religious disillusionment args
to have the character dramatically turn
on everything they believed
scorning it behind them there's this
inbuilt
cynicism that likes to divide religion
into the easy good and bad the
testaments is
a disillusionment story but there's also
this intense sympathy for that struggle
to let go
in every line there's this empathy for
how
faith can be a part of who you are on a
really
fundamental level while also
understanding that
it can be weaponized against you almost
without you realizing in many ways but
what made this really profound for me
is that in normal disillusionments
you'll usually see the
institution itself revealed to be
corrupt or evil or at least
represented by evil characters and there
definitely
are evil characters in gilead behind it
all
but that would really put a lot of
effort to communicate
how these systems that are around us can
be
passively harmful what i mean by that is
that these systems and
cycles survive because it's easy to
fight
malicious conscious obvious evil where
we can
point a finger and say it's his fault
get him
but it's hard to fight evil that is
passively accepted
as normal where there's not a single
person
behind it where we can't point a finger
and say hey
it's your fault and then the evil goes
away
because it isn't orchestrated by any bad
person it's reinforced by our biases
by the justifications that we make
inwardly to ourselves before we make
them to
others there is a very real hierarchy in
gilead but the handmaid's tale and the
testaments are about the power of these
community norms
about how they can reframe things to
make them
seem more okay and that that itself
is a lot harder to fix on technical
level the writing is just brilliant it's
beautiful it's poetic
the opening immediately drags you into
the world story and perspective with
aunt lydia comparing how a statue
depicts her with
how she views herself which really fits
into the way the story is told
it is told by the way from the
perspective of someone who orchestrates
the horrors
of this gilead society she is not a good
guy
but it really does make her perspective
compelling it pulled me through from
line to line the story is also split
into two other perspectives two girls
that aunt lydia is
training and a lot of stories really
struggle with split perspectives because
one character is more clearly driving
the plot or one character has
a more interesting commentary on the
world uh
and that is slightly the case aunt lydia
is more interesting than these two girls
but it was never enough of a problem
because
all three perspectives are interesting
immersive and compelling with
their own arcs and ways of looking at
the world none of them felt like filler
and edward masterfully wove all three
perspectives together
there is this whole subplot about how
lydia ended up
in this position of power that she was
once a judge
in modern america before it fell and she
found a new place in the society
we learn about what she had to do to
survive what she chose to do
and what kind of person she is
how she was conditioned to do evil and
how she
justified it to herself and that is a
really interesting commentary to make
it's a very
psychological story and it's very
skillfully juxtaposed
with this girl who is
unlearning all of these harmful things
that she was taught and conditioned to
believe
it's these two stories of opposite
intensity dealing with the same
thing and this juxtaposition just really
works
it is largely written in first person
and
it's a great study on how to do that in
a more adult context
we see a lot of first person in y a and
this
takes that familiar style that you might
like and brings it into a more
mature level on a meditation level
it's a fascinating look at how to
incorporate different styles of writing
because there are
witness transcripts diary entries uh
lectures
and seeing how they can feed into one
another
and seeing how uh you can write them in
a compelling way because sometimes
it feels limiting to kind of like force
yourself into a into a format like that
um but edward really does manage to do
it she really does manage to use those
different mediums
gilead is a very dark and grim world the
testaments will rarely make you smile
but it is incredibly real and believable
a lot of the time we see dystopian
societies and you get left with this
feeling of oh how did this happen how
did this government even manage to take
power in the first place
but this story was so emotionally
real for me that you can look at the
people in this story and go oh i
understand how these people let this
happen
how these people got behind this
and let the society come to be you see
yourself
in their weaknesses i also want to say
don't let how you might not have enjoyed
the handmade's tale put you off from
reading the testaments
little secret i didn't like it either
but i loved this
it's a lot more digestible it's faster
paced
lydia is a lot more of a personality
than offer it is
and there's a lot more tension plot
while still being poetic
and deep no it's not a flashy story like
a lot of dystopias out there
but if you go into it with that in mind
i think that the testaments
is a great way to expand your reading
tastes beyond
what you might normally read what can i
say but that i am in awe of atwood's
writing especially with the nuance that
she deals with the topics she discusses
i cannot recommend the testaments enough
if you want to know what i'm reading or
how i rate other books then come follow
me on goodreads i just got one
it's a lot of fun it's all very new to
me links down below